behind everything that has ever happened
is happening or ever will happen there
is a gradient we are slaves to the
gradient this episode was made possible
by generous supporters on patreon okay
crazy before I get too nihilistic here
let's let's ask your process question um
what's a gradient yes this is gonna be
fun let's start with the definition the
gradient represents the greatest
increase in a number across space hmm
greatest increase can we do with this
say you're standing on a hill you could
move north south east west or some
combination of those at each location
you have an elevation measured
vertically from the bottom of the hill
so now we've got a bunch of numbers
assigned to different points in space
wait a minute that's what we call a
field a number or set of numbers
assigned to each point in space in this
case that number is elevation so we'll
call this an elevation field any
direction you move on the hill will
change that elevation the direction of
the gradient is the direction you can
walk that will give you the quickest
change in elevation but this gradient
also depends on location so it's also a
field just like the elevation is a
number assigned to each point in space
the gradient is an arrow assigned to
each point in space the direction of
each of those arrows is the direction of
greatest increase in elevation and their
size tells us how quickly that increase
is happening at this point though some
of you might be wondering but like why
does any of this matter because it tells
us what's gonna happen
elevation isn't the only number we can
assign two points in space say you've
got a tank full of water let's imagine
the water is made of very tiny water
cubes each of those cubes has a pressure
exerted on it from the surrounding views
we'll measure that pressure as a number
and assign it to the cube and we'll do
the same for all the other cubes in the
tank this is something we might call a
pressure field just like we did with
elevation we now have a pressure
assigned two points in space
it's that perfectly uniform throughout
the tank though it's higher at the
bottom than it is at the
that's what we call a pressure gradient
and it points in the direction of
greatest increase in this case straight
downward that gradient is important
because pressure can control what
happens the gradient of pressure is a
force actually when you work out the
unit you go fourth density now force
close enough also force isn't a positive
gradient it's a negative ring
remind me again why you had to come back
from vacation I miss you okay okay back
to the tank say we put something else
into the tank like a bowling ball it's
going to experience the pressures from
the surrounding water cues what those
pressures are larger on the bottom than
they are on the top this results in an
upward force per unit volume much better
that bowling ball is displacing a
particular volume of water the pressure
gradient across that volume gives us a
force something we call a buoyant force
if that buoyant force is strong enough
to overpower gravity the bowling ball
will float yes some bowling balls float
the heavier ones safe but the lighter
ones can float if they're under 12
pounds or so the reason that happens is
because of a pressure gradient for that
matter it's why a lot of things happen
it's what allows you to breathe it's
what creates wind and it's why a portal
between Denver and New York would be a
very bad idea but that bowling ball
example had another force in it gravity
which is also the result of ingredient
in energy gradients Saxon is basically a
pressure or is it every density so
pressure gradient is an energy density
gradient I'm not sure how that insight
is helpful here but thanks so energy
gradients at every possible location
inside this tank the bowling ball has an
energy given to it by the earth those
energies increase as you move up in the
tank so the energy gradient is straight
upward this gradient causes a force and
as nerd clon mentioned that force is
going to be the negative or opposite of
the gradient it'll point downward which
is exactly what you'd expect for gravity
mathematically we'd write the gradient
like this the change in energy over the
distance in the upward direction to get
the force of gravity we just
take the negative or opposite of that
that means gravity points in the
direction of greed is decrease in energy
which is downward this is a really
simple example though the energy only
changes in one direction in some other
example it might change in two
directions or even three we do live in a
three-dimensional space after all if we
add a term for each of the other
directions we get this of course that
looks kind of nasty
so weari label it with a single symbol
the NA blah
it's an old Greek word for harp
apparently I guess it kind of looks like
a harp but it's really just an upside
down Delta for change a change in some
number across space lots of measurements
can be different in different places and
those differences are what cause things
to happen weather patterns on the earth
are caused by pressure and temperature
gradients buoyancy is caused by a
pressure gradients Newtonian gravity is
caused by an energy gradient yeah yeah I
know gravity's really the curvature of
space-time but there's still a gradient
it's just beyond the scope of this video
concentration gradients are a waste
cells exchange molecules with their
surroundings we call it passive
transport fluid motion gradient brain
function gradients electromagnetic
interactions gradients the eventual heat
death of the universe is literally the
end of all gradients if there's no more
gradients that's it that's the end
nothing will ever happen again
ever probably behind everything that has
ever happened is happening or ever will
happen there is a gradient we are slaves
to the gradient all the gradients so how
do you feel about this are you okay
being a slave to the gradient or do you
think we can rise above it
please share your thoughts in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video a special thanks goes out to
patreon patrons like Ken Davis who
helped keep this show going with their
generous support don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
to everyone who commented about
perpetual motion machines no those don't
suddenly become possible even though
more dark energy is being created over
time it remains perfectly uniform
throughout space which means there's no
gradient which means we can't use it
anyway thanks for watching